[Music]
it's not just like Papadopoulos drops in
out of nowhere you have all this stuff
going on in the summer before we get the
Papadopoulos information you got all
this information coming out about what
the Russians are doing with the hacking
and the dumping of emails clearly
intended to have an impact on our
political system and then in the midst
of that that's when we get the
Papadopoulos information you know that
from a former general counsel of the FBI
Jim Baker about our next guest George
Stephanopoulos says that Papadopoulos I
just got you in the Stephanopoulos that
would have been a fun story they said if
he has only just begun to lay out the
timeline of when he believes the Obama
Intel agencies were attempting to entrap
him and he joins us now now George what
haven't you ever revealed to date is
just you know how many agencies were
coming after you one person and
something that they tried to get your
girlfriend to do what was that oh my god
thanks a lot for having me Laura so
besides the FBI trying to have my then
girlfriend now wife actually wear a wire
to try and entrap me herself which was
completely crazy
she was an Italian citizen visiting me
as a girlfriend and they subpoenaed her
and basically tried to flip her against
me which was incredibly bizarre but what
we believed they really targeted her for
was because she actually knew all about
Joseph mipz woods connections to the
Italian government and his connections
in Europe which we just recently found
out today that the Italian government
under the presidency of that country the
Prime Minister I should say just fired
the heads of three Intel agencies in
Italy and I think it has to do with this
person Joseph Mifsud who the president
and Devon Nunez and other people have
been asking the government and Italy to
examine a lot more because he's actually
at the core of this entire scam yeah
people forget about these figures I mean
this starts to read like a John Locke or
a novel the way this entire thing is
played out but you've heard the
Democrats and what they're saying
they're saying this was well predicated
you had
brennon last night I think we'll play
the video he was on television last
night again and claiming that this was
all this is all copacetic let's watch I
do believe it's important that there be
an understanding about just how strongly
predicated that investigation was I was
there in the summer of 16 and it was
very well predicated well predicated
George I want to make it very clear that
by the time that I joined the Trump
campaign before my name was even public
an FBI intermediary named Arvinder Samba
at a company I used to work for in
London introduced me to this person
Joseph Mifsud at a company at a school I
should say called lean campus which the
CIA and the FBI trains at fast forward
to April of 2016 I'm I'm the Australian
government is reaching out trying to
connect with me 10 Downing Street is
connecting with me and then of course
which I find very suspicious is that the
DIA reached out to me at the US Embassy
in London these two individuals named
Gregory Baker and Terence Dudley just
days before this infamous meeting I had
with Alexander Downer who I've testified
under oath and I've reported both to the
FBI and Bob Muller
that I felt that he was a spying on me
and something I want to you know make
clear about this meeting with downer I
don't think I was just suspicious that
he was spying on me because I'm in my
transcripts to Congress you see people
like mark meadows and John Radcliffe
asking me if I ever was presented with
transcripts of any meetings I had with
Alexander Downer Josef Mifsud or any of
these strange people that were running
into me and I said no so I think
Congress probably has transcripts they
probably already know and the president
already knows that these people were
spying and that's going to be a big
bombshell moving forward now you've got
me really interested in this ok I love
the transcripts the tidbit thank you so
much